I wanted to know about
um this is completely unrelated to
anything uh this is a great Channel
called Nile green what do you think
about this channel wait what is it I
thought that the error of now green is
over is it really we don't talk about it
anymore is it really no it wasn't hungry
what is what is you've seen Nile green
no I mean I know of nail red yeah so I
assume it's something to do so there was
a guy another Australian man these guys
are very good yeah he's probably my mate
yeah yeah uh he at the time I didn't I
think I knew I knew he's Australian
because you go to the about page it said
Australia
but he
would put my voice into uh like an AI
bot okay he literally had like a perfect
voice Channel yeah that would basically
like learn your kind of cadence and how
you sound and then you could type out
what you want the person to say
anything funny it's kind of like I would
say it's similar to like not a bad deep
fake but I'd say like an okay deep fake
in terms of like voice faces right where
it's like oh it's close enough that if
you're if you're not paying attention
you might be tricked but if you like
actually pay attention yeah you're like
okay that's clearly you can see like you
take a second artifacting so when I
first heard it like this guy would make
these videos right and I heard it and
like for the first like yeah like 30
seconds I'm like I never said this and
like then you hear it and go okay this
is clear like it's a robot it's like a
parody channel right yeah but they would
do like these parodies which were
actually good like I would say very very
good like it's not like those low level
parodies where they're like oh he does
chemistry again like I know Breaking Bad
let's combine the two I'll just do like
some like chemistry meme stuff yeah he
had he would like reference things that
were like very obscure and I watched it
I'm like this guy has to have a chem
background right but he has to know
chemistry because he would be even
making like references to like chemical
processes and I'm just like again
they're not like super in-depth but I'm
like this guy knows chemistry
like he knows that you can't Channel and
he's he didn't just learn it from
watching the channel like he knows
you've got to watch this it's stuff's
crazy now you're describing and even the
filming like he would do things where
like
this guy knows how to edit like it's
it's an insane amount of work just for a
parody like he would do things where I'm
like I don't even know how he edited
that was that like flattering or was it
like what the [ __ ] is happening I watch
I loved it when I first watched it I was
like I thought it was so funny the
problem was that like after he had made
like five or six videos
it was when people started being
confused they thought it was me I was
like I was like okay this is like kind
of thought it was like a second Channel
or something yeah because he even copied
the aesthetic and the gloves and like
the lab coats sometimes like he would it
would look really similar to the point
where people thought it was me right and
I was like okay if this guy's bad
intentions yeah he could actually like
like someone kind of commented on it he
goes if this guy just like started doing
like really racist stuff really like you
know kind of like just offend holy
offensive or even illegal stuff yeah
it's like it people might think I'm
doing it yeah and then I get in trouble
right right that's that's crazy that
we've gotten to the point now where
someone can like impersonate deep fake
your voice yeah to the point where they
can genuinely like affect your
livelihood yeah because the the the
machine is so good at imitating it I
need it it is crazy I got to see this I
just play a little I'll play it oh no
I'll play a little audio clip real quick
I got bored feeding wieners to my acid
so today I felt like exploding some
sulfuric acid here is my stick of
dynamite this is made with love like
it's not perfect but it's shocking how
good it is but even even the aesthetic
yeah yeah just to prove this is sulfuric
acid here is the pH let me reiterate
this is the pH so he did make the things
like he did make piranha there so when I
watched it I'm like it wasn't just like
an effect like he has concentrated
sulfuric acid yeah and hydrogen peroxide
and he's making legitimately like a very
dangerous concoction yeah so like this
guy knows chemicals so that's the thing
too is like he wasn't just deep faking
it he was good at video editing putting
the videos together Kim worth almost
like some kind of movie where someone
started replacing it yeah yeah like I
think that I've actually been movie
plots that are legit that right yeah so
you reach out to him so he
since he's Australian and there's very
few Australian uh like YouTube creators
yeah I guess too absolutely I wish you
went to chemistry so he knew the other
uh but I said the Australian guy yeah uh
explosions and fire
um
I don't know who reached out to who but
Tom who runs explosions of fire told me
he's like hey dude like I've spoken to
him yeah yeah so then now there was like
um a connection a connection right right
uh so then we ended up just like he
wanted to do another video or he wanted
to talk to me so I'm like okay I'll talk
to him I ended up saying like if you
want to make another video that's fine
like I don't want to just come in here I
think it's funny I don't want to come in
here and just be like shut down yeah
your time is done and I'm like but if
you keep making it like I'll probably
have to do that because you are like is
potentially a liability yeah and I'm
like I don't think you have any bad
intentions but it could go it could go
the wrong way and I'm like I don't think
it's unreasonable that people are
thinking that I run this Channel and
there's like some issues it could be
like I could see if someone is maybe
want to want to see your videos in
passing and they find this Channel and
it's branded a little too similarly they
got a lot of views oh no they they have
a [ __ ] ton of you so it's like it was
enough people that I was like it's gonna
cause problems but it was very
reasonable he's like oh I agree so he's
like that's good yeah that's good but he
also said he goes like and it makes
sense from a guy who put that much
effort and made such like high quality
stuff yeah as a parody like the amount
of work that went in was insane yeah he
goes I like filmmaking I like writing he
goes I I don't want to be just a guy who
parodies one person yeah and he was
that's like it was what I'm just in
forever just making parodies of you he
goes that sounds horrible to me yeah so
he's like I want to do YouTube I want to
figure out like the type of content I
want to make so he goes I was gonna
phase it out anyway okay oh so it was
kind of you know yeah so he's like do
you mind if I make like one or two more
videos and I was like look if you have
really good ideas for both yeah you can
make two I'm like but if you only have
like one hype video that you know of now
and he's like yeah I don't really know
what I do for the other one I'm like
then probably just stick to one yeah so
he did and then he I even said after
that too should probably change like the
channel from like 9 green to something
else and he did like I didn't he just
ended up like a month or two later he
ended up just like changing oh that's
good that's oh he was like he clearly
was not a malicious person right yeah we
had him on our podcast too oh yeah okay
okay I wonder like if let's say somebody
used your voice I'm like could you
copyright claim that yeah that's a very
interesting question well I've never
copied where I claimed my own image you
know like if somebody because it's you
know you have image rights yeah but I
don't know if there's any laws of voice
rights uh you know vocal rights already
it's it's I think it's like one of those
areas that you get into that you're just
gonna if you I would say if you have
enough money you can sue anybody yeah of
course but if you don't want to bleed
yourself dry trying to like it's like
what I I assume with every dollar I have
right right and now you stop making
these videos but I have no money and I
didn't I just want to like let's say you
know if someone clearly imitating my
voice and it's good enough where people
generally think it's me and I copyright
claim them and then they counterclaim I
wonder if what YouTube would be like huh
I don't think you can so copyright is
for like a a published work
so I don't like your voice the tone of
your voice is not copyrightable
I don't think but I think that like
if people stealing your likeness is this
is your likeness right that's not
illegal they would have to seal it and
you have to prove damages
well it's it yeah I think this is a
whole new [ __ ] territory because yeah
this is never it yeah it's never really
become a big something left to deal with
the next few years obviously the closest
is like impersonators who would just buy
their voice yeah yeah exactly but it was
like unless they're damaging you like if
they're just yeah I get that makes sense
if they're selling your likeness and
they're like going on the street like
I'm so and so and everyone who walks by
is a kid this is not the guy yeah he's
an impersonator but it's like if you
actually start like pretending and then
making videos of yourself and making
fake videos trying to convince the
public that this person is doing
horrible things like then you can be
sued but that's a crime like you're
you're defaming them and yeah yeah like
potentially identity like it's identity
theft yeah but it's like just copying
the voice yeah I mean my first content
was impersonation mainly so I mean
you have a charge fear I was charged for
Minecraft no I I I I'm good friends with
the poor sector actually what did you do
I was anime and I used to copy a voice
of one of the characters and just make
videos about that and then yeah that's
like you pretended you were them or you
they people no I never said I was them
yeah I I didn't go around being like hey
it's me I was like I'm pretending to be
this character and for the first few
weeks people were very confused because
because I was still small and they're
like oh the guy they made a side Channel
yeah yeah I I didn't brand it as like
I'm them or anything it was just like
I'm impersonated the voice and did
stupid stuff that maybe could be
considered damages who knows because
I've actually thought about this because
I was just thinking how much audio
content is there of my voice oh people
can for sure yeah yeah it's just a lot
of hours of trash taste that we put on
oh God yeah you can easily make a
[ __ ] deep fake and like I've
literally seen like some meme videos
because we talk a lot on trash days yeah
and I I there's like I can hear a voice
line that's clearly me and I recognize
that it's me I have no recollection of
ever saying that in my life
that's a very weird feeling too yeah
like just thinking that like not
remembering
yeah yeah that's true
yeah so it's it's it's kind of scary and
weird whenever whenever that happens and
yeah I think that's how I felt when I
watched the first the Deep page that
must have been so creepy no but I was
just like I didn't say this yeah right I
remember saying I don't remember this
video do you have a like a [ __ ] split
personality yeah then you start like
questioning your sanity like okay now
I don't remember putting the dynamite in
the asses yeah it's like I despise it I
just it's confusion for like a little
while it's like that seems like
something I would do but I just have no
recollection of actually